UNCORROBORATED ACCUSATIONS.
HERE IS WHAT HAPPENED.
>> Tucker: IT IS HARD FOR MOST
OF US TO IMAGINE WHAT IT MUST BE
LIKE TO BE BRETT KAVANAUGH.
DAVID SORENSON HAS SOME IDEA.
HE ONCE WORKED AS A WHITE HOUSE
SPEECHWRITER.
HE WAS FIRED AFTER "THE
WASHINGTON POST" PUBLISHED AN
ARTICLE ACCUSING HIM OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE.
WITHOUT A CONVICTION OR SOLID
EVIDENCE AND WITHOUT MUCH TIME
TO RESPOND TO THE CHARGES, HE
LOST HIS JOB.
HIS REPUTATION WAS DESTROYED.
IF CURRENT TREND CONTINUE, A LOT
OF PEOPLE MIGHT LEARN WHAT THAT
IS LIKE.
DAVID SORENSON JOINS US TO TELL
US.
THANKS A LOT FOR COMING ON.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: I'LL SAY IT UP FRONT.
I KNOW NOTHING ABOUT YOUR
MARRIAGE OR THE DETAILS EVEN OF
THIS CASE.
ALL I KNOW IS THAT YOU DID NOT
HAVE A CHANCE TO RESPOND.
THERE DIDN'T SEEM TO BE CONCRETE
EVIDENCE THESE CHARGES WERE
TRUE.
THEY WERE MADE BY SOMEONE WHO, I
THINK, HAD MOTIVE TO MAKE THEM.
THE CONSEQUENCES YOU SUFFERED
WERE OVERWHELMING.
WHAT WAS YOUR RESPONSE TO THIS?
>> WELL, I FELT A DEEP AND
PROFOUND FRUSTRATION.
I THINK JUDGE KAVANAUGH IS
FEELING THAT RIGHT NOW AS WE
SPEAK.
I NEVER THOUGHT I WOULD FEEL IN
MY LIFE.
THE FEELING OF HAVING YOUR
REPUTATION THAT YOU'VE SO
CAREFULLY BUILT OVER SO MANY
YEARS BE DESTROYED IN AN INSTANT
AND FURTHER MORE FOR MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE TO BELIEVE THESE BASELESS
ACCUSATIONS SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY
FIT A POLITICAL NARRATIVE IS
INCREDIBLY FRUSTRATING.
I COULDN'T IMAGINE HOW DIFFICULT
IT MUST BE.
I COULD, FOR JUDGE KAVANAUGH,
AND THE SITUATION HE IS IN RIGHT
NOW.
IT IS TERRIBLE.
YOUR REPUTATION IS SOMETHING
THAT.
>> Tucker: YOU CAN'T GET BACK.
THERE ARE LOTS OF CRIMES
COMMITTED IN THIS COUNTRY ALL
THE TIME.
IN ALMOST ALL OF THEM, WE WAIT
TO HEAR THE EVIDENCE AND THEN WE
WEIGH IT TO THE SIDE WHAT WE
THINK OF IT.
IN THIS ONE SPECIFIC CATEGORY OF
ALLEGED CRIME, WE WEIGHED IT
DRAMATICALLY TO ONE SIDE.
DID YOU FEEL LIKE YOU HAD THE
ONUS OF PROVING THAT YOU WEREN'T
A DOMESTIC ABUSER?
DID YOU FEEL LIKE PEOPLE
AUTOMATICALLY BELIEVED YOUR
EX-WIFE?
>> YES, ABSOLUTELY.
EVEN THOUGH THERE WAS NO
EVIDENCE WHATSOEVER.
IT WAS SIMPLY A BASELESS
ALLEGATION.
IT CONTRADICTS EVERYTHING WE
HAVE LEARNED THROUGHOUT OUR
LIVES ABOUT JUSTICE, ABOUT
FAIRNESS.
IT CONTRADICTS THE LEGAL SYSTEM
THAT WE HAVE BUILT UP CAREFULLY
OVER CENTURIES TO CREATE A FAIR
FORM FOR GETTING TO THE BOTTOM
OF THE TRUTH.
IT IS REALLY SCARY HOW THE LEFT
IS WAGING A WAR ON THE BASIC
BUILDING BLOCKS OF OUR
CIVILIZATION WHETHER IT COMES TO
PRIORITIES LIKE TRUTH, FAIRNESS,
MERRITT, REASON.
THESE ARE THINGS THAT ARE THROWN
RIGHT OUT THE WINDOW AT THE
EXPENSE OF THEIR PURSUIT OF
POLITICAL POWER.
IT IS ALSO EQUALLY SHAMEFUL TO
SEE THE MEDIA PARTICIPATE IN IT
SO AGRE
SO EGREGIOUSLY WHEN THEY USED TO
BE CONSIDERED.
IDEALLY, THEY WERE CONSIDERED TO
BE ANN ARBOR ARBITOR OF TRUTH.
THEY ARE PARTICIPATING IN THESE
SMEAR JOBS.
>> IT IS A SAD AND OMINOUS TREND
FOR THOSE OF US THAT HAVE SONS.
>> IT IS TERRIBLE.
YOUR REPUTATION IS SOMETHING
THAT'S GAINED BY THE RAIN DROP
AND LOST BY THE BUCKETFUL.
JUDGE KAVANAUGH IS LEARNING THAT